it's a telephone pole
she said that's a telephone pole she is
right plenty of damage the past 24 hours
here in the valley
including downed trees ripped up
carports a lot of flooding
and again all of this happened in the
past 24 hours thank you for joining us
at six i'm brian loftus i'm denise
valdez we have weather team coverage
tonight we continue now with madison
kimbrough who is over in the corrupt
valley speedway where they had some
severe flooding as we saw there madison
yeah conditions here at the pahrump
valley speedway are extensive now we
showed you the road leading up to it
now take a look behind me as you can see
the speedway is
entirely flooded out and if that weren't
enough broken windows down
trees and parts of the roof caved in
neighboring businesses also got hit hard
with damage
people at the speedway say this has been
years since they have seen this amount
of flooding and unfortunately
the damage will cost them the winds were
so bad it tore a lot of things apart
it shattered our windows in the back
tore our snack bar completely apart
our carly's pizza we lost the roof on it
the whole inside of that was tore up
several residents in pahrump lost power
last night around 10
30 and when talking with chad he said
their power just turned back on around 5
15
this afternoon so keep it here on 8 news
now as we are going to cover this area
of pahrump all night so we are bringing
you the latest coverage
reporting live in pahrump madison
kimbrough 8 news now